um you're racially ambiguous yeah what
is your what's your break it down man
bro I swear to God bro so uh people
always assume I'm like
Puerto Rican or like a Mexican off the
bat right I'm I'm Creole bro I'm like
black white French Indian you feel me
like I always figured you were like
Mexican a little bit of Brazilian in
there you know what I mean a little bit
but but
really like that's really why I'm like
this too like my whole life like you
feel me from the time I was born I was
never black enough for the right black
kids to accept me and I was like too
black for the the next white kids you
know what I mean so it kind of left me
in like a weird place and I had to kind
of be more extra out than you should be
to to be be accepted by by who I wanted
to be accepted by you know what I mean
so I had to be look if you if you ever
see this is the truest [ __ ] ever
if you ever see a a group of hood [ __ ]
in the whitest one in the group is
probably crazy as [ __ ] bro like let me
just would you say you were the craziest
one in your group
I had quick reaction times that's all
I'm gonna say yeah I had quick reactions
I respond to things like instantly but
now you know I do MMA everything you've
definitely grown a lot I was gonna say
are you ever worried that like
um some old chicken yeah all the time
like all the time you're a new level in
life mentally all the time bro I always
think like damn like
because I know people can hold a grudge
for a long [ __ ] time so I'm always
just Super Hyper aware of like of myself
and and my surroundings and everything
like that because
you know you'll never know like as I'm
saying like I'm pretty sure like my
Karma's like pretty even now after
everything you know I should be about
here now but uh you'll never know you
know what I mean so I'm always hyper
aware of my surroundings and like even
even when I meet people I have wrong
before I saw somebody
at a bar that I arrived in high school
and I was like damn bro like I'm sorry
bro like I'm not gonna you ain't gonna
get it back but I'm I feel terrible
about it you know I mean like man you
want to drink you know what I mean like
some [ __ ] like that it happens he was
with like he was with like eight people
and I was like all by myself too [ __ ] I
had like one homie with me my homie was
like a five two like like like Asian
dude and he didn't do nothing so I was
like thank God he could have whipped my
ass right there now he had about eight
people with him I was like damn this is
gonna be oh bad I'm gonna be all over
the gram tonight Jesus he ain't do
nothing though but at the end of the day
like I do MMA every day
uh because like you know cap got me on
that type program I wake up every
morning I I go to the gym I do my my my
my uh MMA are you doing Muay Thai or
just yeah two or more time I do like
Muay Thai and and boxing yeah but like
it just helps me keep my my mind
straight and also keeps my reaction time
on point so if I gotta hit somebody up
in the jaw and get the [ __ ] out of there
that's that's possible you know what I
mean and bro just that Muay Thai [ __ ]
like
I ain't gonna lie like uh
I actually see like uh where's in there
every day I'm like and this [ __ ] like a
goddamn uh a ninja you feel me I'm
trying to get on that type time